this first time I've used the IMAX
camera it's terrific and very easy to
use great clarity everything is crisp we
compared them to other cameras and a
number of testings and saw it projected
up there and said guys this is the way
we have to go we spent two weeks trying
to come up with the framing for the film
and and to protect four to four oh and
how it worked and on the second day of
shooting Flint said you know what I'm
shooting an IMAX movie I'm framing for
IMAX it was important that Clint told
the story as accurately as it could and
with the kind of respect we feel for the
story ourselves
Sully's such an inspiring story of a guy
who's just doing this thing and then all
of a sudden he has to become a hero and
I read the script I saw what cliff saw
in it and I knew right away this is a
Clint Eastwood film I shot it in the
IMAX format
that was the way it was planned
originally brace for impact
would you get so much of that
environment it really puts you in the
moment got an a320 diving for the
ribbons want to try to land runway once
right the old days there was much more
top and bottom and then when scope came
out everybody went for the horizontal
look and people are used to that but
when you're on boats and rafts planes
you're running up and down aisles it's
nice to have the IMAX ratio it's just
this bore top and bottom to the filter
this is an ideal way to see if you're
filming
you